man anyway he locked and loaded last
night you're right first what were you
saying
i just saw the volusia dog move this
over oh you get nervous about it yeah i
can't nervous because you
you have it like life on the edge right
right on the [ __ ] edge i'm like hey
come on finally what you and your girl
watch it
no uh me uh white mike oh white mike
yeah white mike we watched it he needs
to stop betting you by the way
but anyways uh yeah damn that's intense
right
it was intense especially like towards
the end but like
i mean his story is amazing isn't it
great it's a great
it's a good dog it's a good story like
his come up and
just how he he [ __ ] had it in him and
he just like
you know he was a tortured soul though
yeah notes to his girl
oh my gosh they got like all he because
he would always
move to l.a his girl was like back in
new york so that was like
love of his life he'd always write her
notes yeah it was like
it was pretty he was going through it
man how long has a doc
hours change oh yeah hours of change
it's really it's
really good but it's not like official
like no or it's like the way they do it
like
they don't have like i don't know they
do like told from my kids family and
friends
yeah every really dope no one's like
sitting down and like you see the
person's face and
all of it's through phone it's so well
done but it's so well done
you know what's interesting in the night
that he died uh at that
chateau uh
a ton of people have died there but when
he you know when he died there the night
when he overdosed uh robert de niro
and robert uh and uh robert
and robin williams were in his room de
niro went i guess de niro went
knocked on his door the next day to like
check it out but he
but he didn't answer but he didn't think
anything of it crazy right
but come to find out he he was dead and
the girl the girl who sold him
the eight baller with the [ __ ] did she
get in trouble or something oh yeah she
went to prison
she went to prison yeah damn yeah she
did time for that
yeah because but why
uh help me out with that one it's like
the same it's like the person who sold
uh
mac miller the fentanyl yeah they caught
him yeah i mean yeah
oh really in prison oh yeah how did they
know who sold it
probably just right tax yeah trace it
back because what what did mack miller
take
he was doing heroin right but it was
laced with heroin heroin or
cocaine it was laced with fentanyl yeah
really what yeah that fentanyl [ __ ] is
but no cocaine and alcohol that boy is
partying
oh fentanyl damn he uh because he makes
the fentanyl with the cocaine man he uh
ideally yeah i met him when he was with
uh ariana grande
yeah because they had
super nice guy super nice short he was
real short
super nice guy and just so giggly yeah
well he was
he was young though man yeah 26. i know
i was a fan too that's such a bummer
yeah damn that drone was coming drugs to
get you
yeah it was but yeah that belushi dude
speaking of drugs
dude i did that what did you do would
you do something no i don't
i did mike tyson wanted me to do so i
did a food truck diet with mike tyson
he does a lot of drugs he does he does a
lot of drugs
like what you saw that clip on the hot
box but what's weird
like he does shrooms that makes him like
friendlier i guess is why he does them
but he
and he's taking a lot of them and i'm
not talking like micro dosing he you
know he's taking a ton of troops because
i know that microdosing is the thing for
shrooms like he's not micro
he's mad macro he's macro he's
he's full blown so he's going to do
pizza i don't know i don't know the
[ __ ] take of shrooms and
i don't know i don't know either but he
he does them all the time and he just
feels better on which to each its own
that's fine but he
uh yes it's a good episode he gets he
gets
really high and then he kept dropping
kept dropping the end bomb on me i know
he hey listen and in my head i'm like
is someone you tell him i'm not black is
he so high he stinks off
bro he called i think he called everyone
inwards because he was like on ryan
garcia he was like tank this is
this thing he could beat you yeah but
he's running out of tank another black
guy no he wasn't wrong
they had taken no he was i was their dog
oh own hotbox yeah he
he was saying the n word and tank was on
the phone oh oh you saying he was you
yeah
this is another black guy in the
conversation it's just me and him
yeah yeah yeah okay that's what's weird
because it feels it just felt
weird like hold off yeah i've never
heard him talk like that yeah you're
like
man
no i did a podcast with them probably
no probably four years ago five years
ago before hop boxing no
we did it in santa monica up the street
when he was just starting in a podcast
and it was awful
i thought it was it was his own it was
his own show he used to do it with uh he
was like a new york radio dj i forget
the guy's name
rosenberg or something like that oh oh
oh for uh high nine seven
i think yeah i think it was him yeah the
the one the rest
of the show was uh bro in the morning
yeah yeah yeah i'm saying that's
rosenberg
it was him and uh tyson and tyson at the
time i brought it up to him like dude do
you remember when we did
that and he was like bro those were the
cocaine days
what yeah because he didn't say much he
was just like zoning out he's like
you're still doing cocaine yeah he's
like that when i just do a bunch of
cocaine i like i didn't talk i didn't
say much i was like yeah you didn't not
see him there dude
like he might as well been you know that
[ __ ] clock on the wall
like it was me brian and rosenberg talk
and then
then tyson was just like staring at the
lights
did you try to engage him in the
conversation a little he just wasn't
having it and i was like dog the 180
you've done from that to
now is insane he completely changed his
life complete dude
he's a sweet dude that he that he's
hooked up to
it's like this muscle machine yeah what
is this yeah it's like electro
like uh stimulus uh machine you're
talking about
yeah i've seen them like using this
thing in it like i don't know
[ __ ] then we ordered food and he
didn't touch the food because like and i
didn't know they just wanna do shrooms
you don't you don't wanna eat
uh when you do psychedelics you don't
like you're not hungry at all okay so
it's just my
fat ass eating while she just talked
yeah
all right man you gotta eat you so he
rode up in here
like a basic [ __ ] with some
doug uh that good for you yeah avocado
is good for you
very good for you it is a lot of fat i'm
looking for my
it's good fat all the women eat them
though i you do got a point though oh
yeah no no i wouldn't say basically i i
don't think i
don't think i've seen it's a
i slice the tomatoes on top little
balsamic vinegar look at you getting all
cute with this [ __ ] what's up dog
all of a sudden chappelle gets a new
high tight haircut
why are you mad at your barber bro he
want to quit his job because he made so
much money in the stock market
no ain't no good for you you should
celebrate no hell no
he had occupied he needs your hair cut
bro you see me right now right now i'm
like bro
as soon as you put them like teen wolf
how much how much was your how much was
your haircut
forty dollars yeah i mean the forty
dollars ain't cunning bubba he has to
make a living but wait wait we're family
now
okay listen in the black community
listen black barber shops you
your your barbara is like you're adopted
like once you get this
one that one it's like you listen i got
it out he made it out man he didn't make
it out no he didn't make it out he
needed it
no but because of the stock market he
doesn't need that bro
he wants to sit there and cut your hair
what's he doing
bro he made he's doing something with
the stock market so he he was like yo i
started in
june and you know this the stock market
collapsed so it's starting to come back
he was like investing all his money
pulling out he was like bro he made
over forty thousand dollars i said bro
this is outside of the barbershop
outside of the barbershop so the last
time he cut my hair he was telling me
all about it i was like yo it sounded
like he was trying to give me a way out
like bro fine i was gonna find someone
this week i was like hey bro i need my
haircut we're doing a bonus episode he's
like alright i'm gonna let you know on
thursday night he tells me he's like
yeah nah i can't make it in
i got some business hell yeah that's
good for him what
good for the stresses
he should do because obviously 40 grand
the long game he's gonna have to go back
to the haircut
thank you he's just like hey man i was
40. that's just a hundo now
that's what i'm saying hey it's a hundo
now i think i pay 60.
see there it is ooh that you paid 60 for
that yeah i wouldn't have paid 60 though
no
i wasn't done that didn't kiss my ass he
didn't he didn't touch the top he just
did the military
i said i like the late length you
keeping the top
60 dollar haircut dude y'all both won't
get choked out or what
you're talking seriously like yesterday
oh king mustang after dark you looked
great yesterday
i noticed it too yeah why would you you
put a little product in the top
this is worth sixty dollars i don't know
i don't know i got some mexicans up the
street that do it for 20 bucks oh my god
and it was trash
he sent me to him he did oh yeah yeah
well yeah it depends who's mexican did
you get
come on i got this old ass dude i was
like brendan
did he take forever bruh sometimes like
brown come on
yeah that's what i'm talking well yeah
they don't talk
no no you don't have no english going on
in no i'm not bad
and then there's mexican soccer on the
tv yeah it's super nice oh yeah i'm
sorry
i'm sorry yeah really real nice people
though yeah yeah they're good some
are really good but yeah it was just
like i was like this guy it's a crap
shoot
like whoever's open yeah all right next
no okay see i can't do that
well if you know the person you can say
oh i'm gonna wait for you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's almost like he sent me to
this dude he even gave me the dude's
number
yeah so it's like i'm already here yeah
and i'm one of those people
like but you no no i'm one of those
people that i'm like man this guy is
expecting this money
probably so what no this is your hair
but you didn't know that he was gonna
not listen he could do that
ball tapered no he couldn't that's a
ball fade right low ball face yeah
that's a
no dude that's that's what they
specialize in yeah full metal jacket cut
no they could do that dog well no hold
on they don't specialize
i saw his hands i was like bro i'm gonna
sing you to my guy come on now
i saw him on there now your guy's out
too
now you yeah i'm telling you he doesn't
know
the struggles to find remember [ __ ]
cat do you remember when i had that she
clowned me i had a new barber my barber
was out of town making that stock money
i was let me go let me try someone else
she was like cat called me out she was
like yo
your size [ __ ] up even she and he was
like bro look at this [ __ ] well you know
chin
chin can [ __ ] could do that you could
do a ball taper fake
i could yeah well that's good for you
chin yeah but i'm not doing that
yeah you know i don't trust you yeah
it's the same way
do it the same way justin's always like
yeah i'll line you up dawg i'm not doing
that
justin has gold clippers and nobody
touches
we haven't been in here since those uh
[ __ ] wild boys raided the [ __ ]
capital
let's talk about it that was
america's turn to venezuela it's just
like where was the security man
they was letting that it's that easy
yeah but it's daddy like that's
that's how you know he wants to take
over the capitol it's so funny we did
talk [ __ ] to jay
you and i because jay was like he goes
something he says something's going to
happen he said trump
oh yeah yep january 6 and i was and we
were like
no but jay was saying trump something's
gonna happen in the election
and i was like it's over god i thought
he was saying saying something well
that's
that's that's part of the problem it's
over it's
over give it up get the [ __ ] out don't
cause more problems
and then yeah look at that [ __ ] that's
where right now
right now is that the big boy flag he's
got that yellow ball right sure as [ __ ]
is not
please don't associate that don't tread
on me oh
yeah you're just saying you're going to
what's that bucky mace right
right in the face cocky mace all up in
his face
he uh i just i just can't believe that
they were just
just strolled in there and how about how
about the one imagine
being the parents of the one lady who
died the one
who got shot in the [ __ ] young uh
i believe she was she's in the air force
dude yeah she was in the air force and
she was a mom
older woman she came i was she was a
trump she wasn't that old
not old but like she's an adult she was
like yeah oh yeah yeah another kid and
uh
a couple of officers got uh killed as
well i heard one did he got hit in the
head and then died
with a fire extinguisher or something
like that she was 35
young yeah 35 mom like what
out of all this [ __ ] imagine being a
family like and then would you die for
it
would you die for because you wanted for
what you thought it was a regular
election
yeah out there and you saw it by jumping
the gates of the capital like you
thought that was gonna make the change
it's insane dude the capital at all yeah
and you know everyone's like man if they
were black you know what they do them i
don't
see i i don't see it like that i see it
as
these are extremists these are basically
you know
domestic terrorists and they're trump
people they're trump people there's
difference between white people and
trump
correct so they're trump people so trump
advised them and encouraged them to do
this
and then by doing that and then backed
off and let them you know you see the
cops
yep come on in so they weren't shot but
let's say
take any other group take class take a
bun no not black lives take
take a no take white people take uh oh
you saw it take a skateboarding
say a bunch of skateboarders a thousand
skateboarders
decide to do that with no notice let's
say they try it two weeks ago
they would have got shot in the [ __ ]
face it's not it to me so it's not
that there's two americas or it's white
black it's these trump supports and
trump allowed them to do this
because if it was a different group of
white people that
weren't on board with trump dude and
they had their let's say it was
new york giant fans and they wanted to
dude they would shoot them in the face
peter yeah but because they're they're
they're associated with trump they let
him get away with us
it's not that's like this [ __ ] uh well
what was the thing that happened in
kansas at the college i think they were
protesting vietnam
the vietnam war you're talking about
when there was a shooting on the top
massacre
you talking about the shooting ah damn
it
there's this search uh i think
maybe type in wichita massacre
there was something there was something
maybe it was like it was a college and
what's this have to do with raiding the
no i'm just saying like those people
were just protesting against the vietnam
war and they got
shot up just on like on on some no try
it was a college [ __ ] you sure wasn't
texas
it was not texas college massachusetts
kent state kent
state where is that at 1970 ohio ohio
way off more wounded nine other unarmed
constituents by ohio st
national guard and here's what's nuts
yeah days before
the security was like yo do you guys
need backup i'm like no we're good we
got this
huh so now there's an investigation all
of it wait so
so hey come in november or
january 6 do you guys need more security
and they were told no we're good so it's
like
and it makes you closer is going to look
into this and anyone who let this happen
or
decide to give them a pass including
trump dude
they're [ __ ] yeah i mean
they were going against uh weren't they
shouting someone
against pence no i think pence was the
guy who triggered and uh called for the
national guard
and uh they was like not trump pence did
that
that's what i was saying and now pence
is like he said he's gonna go to um
the inauguration and uh but it was funny
i was like yo did you get an invite but
he's going to go
trump's not going yeah trump is not
going any he had to come out yesterday i
was like listen i'm just going to make a
true
uh transition to the next president yeah
yesterday so he so you know you could
touch my copy so you know he uh
you know uh one of the reasons trump
came out and said all that stuff like
because
yeah like i don't agree with this
violence this isn't cools people are
terrorists
because if if you aid in that which he
did earlier on dude it's a problem we
talk about that right now chargement uh
uh what's the guy name who didn't kill
anyone uh charles manson yeah
uh yeah charles didn't kill anyone but
he ate it you know
but also you got to think about like
trump yeah he said that but then he
probably looked at it like oh [ __ ]
they're really doing this no no no no no
no no
you give him too much credit he 100
when he said let's meet let's march and
let's get law and order and like
and tells everyone to line up on that
day to do this stuff
and then not have the proper security i
mean what do you think was going to
happen
if you think he told him to get together
gather and take over the capitol and
didn't think anything was gonna happen
that's insane
that's i mean that's not so you can't
have that yeah well [ __ ]
i mean if you're left all right we can't
have that you know i'm saying we can't
we look like [ __ ] venezuela dude we
can't you can't have it
no i i think i agree with you on on that
point as far as like it's just far left
and far right
but i think that when peter let's say
peter would have like
tried it like a bunch of white women
yeah they were getting shot in the face
i i disagree
you so you think just because they're
white they didn't shoot them yeah
no i don't think so i'm telling you how
like if white people it doesn't it was
because they were loud because trump
organized it and he wasn't they didn't
have the proper security there's a re
it shouldn't be this easy it's it should
not be this easy to invade a capital
there's no [ __ ] cl there's no way so
he has to be in cahoots with it in order
for them not to be penalized and not to
be [ __ ] up yeah i think they wouldn't
get
anywhere i'm saying they wouldn't i'm
telling i'm telling you peter wouldn't
even get across they wouldn't make it
to the wall yeah they're never close
they'll stop them dude you can get
rubber bullets you can get [ __ ] up
okay all right well that's what i'm
thinking i think that like that's what i
yeah that's why i brought up the kent
state things those were white people
that
got got yeah got a national guard for
protesting
but that was in 1970 yeah yeah but i'm
talking about like
we'll go yeah last year or this year
like a lot of black people got killed
by white people yeah by white people
during the black lives mates
it was like too reported like i don't
think you say a lot i'm sorry
well a lot that's not fair well a lot
got injured on a peaceful protest what
can we say that
on a peaceful protest i mean yeah i
don't know the numbers but i don't think
you'd say a lot of people black people
died last year during the
during the black lives mates i think
like four i think four like three of
them like got killed by that guy that 17
year old
uh who came out with that automatic and
the police like tell them we're gonna
hold them off remember that guy uh 17
year old a young kid who shot him
he shot like four that's four right
there and then yeah hold on but he's not
he's not a government official that's a
kid with a gun who was chasing
and that's why he's not doing prison i
don't agree with the [ __ ] he did
yeah but you know that's a kid walking
the streets of wisconsin where the [ __ ]
was that
and then had issues nick's hometown yeah
you know what i'm saying like he's not
like now if he was a cop that did that
yeah you got problems
that's a that's a [ __ ] that's just a
normal that's a kid man
what do you say 30 kills 36 people
facebook post black lives matters
injures a thousand police officers
this has i mean this campaign wait what
no what is some slander i think i think
you can't even check the
statistics on that because there's
always typing yeah you're gonna find
whatever you want but
but i i i wouldn't say that the
protests were like where would you i
wouldn't say black lives matter was
violent
no i was never violent no no but i just
think that i get what you're saying i
just think like
and i'm saying don't get me wrong if
they were black
there's no they would definitely get
[ __ ] up one
10 100 they would have got [ __ ] shot
in the face correct but i'm saying one
of the reasons why they were so
because there's a cahoot yeah because
they were trump supporters
yeah if you can take i and there were i
think there's a few black guys in there
too correct i don't think it matters
they're chinese
black brazilian whatever the [ __ ] they
are if they're part of that trump group
they would have been good
i think it's more of a trump thing than
a white and black thing i saw one boy
one guy there's a black guy there yeah
it was black yeah he was looking for the
stimulus checklist
and and he's saying f black lives
matters
he was playing did we find this guy it
was it was a lot of white people and
then the fbi was like yo
listen we want we want you to help us
help uh help us
like listen if you know anyone who is
affiliated with the capital they have
their pictures
they have their pictures they're gonna
those people are like why is people
coming
i tried to snitch i think i think they
uh arrested like 40 some people
i'll show you i'll send it to you chance
there's a video right here seen i think
you got another video
i think you got to make examples out of
people though so you got to let them
know you can't
[ __ ] with our you know political
institutions
you got to make examples of them you
just can't give them slap on the wrist
oh you got the video that was a picture
of that one black dude
oh you can bring it up if you if you
bring in uh
and it's a is it's a it's a black guy
leaving here
it's all over cnn it's all over fox they
have like the main guys
look at that guy that's him right there
they're looking for
even if you're in a benz yeah you're
still up in a coop
yeah that's the kanye west all falls
down they're gonna
they're gonna
i said it looked like him like airport
that came from power hey look uh it's
crazy but i was trying to like look
what are you doing gee what are you
doing what is he doing he was thinking
like if i was just getting my hat on too
yeah yeah he was like if i'm a stimulus
check where would i hide
you got your stimulus nah i ain't
getting it what's crazy to me is that
one like the one lady who died
crawling up there and then pop
and then everyone wasn't like oh my god
they're shooting they just were like all
right
you see that dude fall that was trying
to climb he tried to climb to the top of
that sun [ __ ] and he fell down
pretty [ __ ] hard that was sad no it
wasn't sad but i mean hey [ __ ] happens
man falls yeah but it goes back to
hold on i'll let you um there should be
a video of it
man died storming the cap no no it's a
different one so do that you know
they had a picture of people like
climbing yeah he fell off yeah oh yeah
he fell
he fell pretty far too he probably
didn't die though i don't think he died
but he got [ __ ] up
that's self-injury
[Music]
but it's crazy crazy though but
chappelle's reference becomes making the
show come to the screeching halt
hey man he was in kansas guy got shot
hey google kansas guys shots i was going
to bring up
uh though there was a guy that was a guy
he was climbing the wall
fell he looked that up hot wall fell
ahead i was going to bring him the board
versus the broad version no the only
reason why i
brought that point because you were
talking about white people and trump
supporters
yeah and i said the people that got shot
at kent state by the national guard
yeah were white people oh yeah you know
and they were protesting the vietnam war
yeah you know what i mean so i i i
understand what you're saying i
understand
what you're saying as well like i'm
saying get a group of
white people together whatever group
they're from like peter peter
and try doing it tomorrow and see what
happens at the capitol do whatever you
want they're gonna get shot in the face
yeah i'm telling you it shouldn't work
like this that's how it worked though
and the only person that got shot was
actually a white a white woman yeah i
don't know
and no one gives a [ __ ] right there's
everyone's just like well that's what
you know
play stupid stupid prizes it's like i
mean
she's your life man yeah no but but we
can't
again i get what you're saying but i was
just trying to bring it back to the
peaceful protest
like you remember everyone was gathering
and stuff like that you saw like people
in minnesota
like the cops would drive by and just
throw tear gas at them and stuff like
that no no
hold on hold on i'm with you and i
support the black lives matter
the message but there's a lot of looting
of course yeah yeah i know that's a
problem oh i'm saying that but but the
problem is they all get lumped together
you know what i'm saying it's like
those those those domestic terrorists
that
invaded the capital like we so all white
people
include like oh all trump supporters are
terrorists no they're not
the 70 million people who vote for him
no they're not that's a small fraction
so like during the black lives matter
like the narrative if you turn on fox
was
oh they're looting they're [ __ ] all
this stuff up no they're not the
majority of them are good people
they're trying to make a change like
they're not they're not destroying these
businesses but they were destroying you
know what i'm saying
like that's those losers are a small
group those people that's a small group
those don't represent the the masses
correct but but
the media the narrative is that they do
the change yeah
exactly exactly and and a shout out to
all the people that like socially
like bringing this to the forefront on
the pod on their platform
as far as like uh like we don't
represent that like
i was watching a lot of sports channels
with uh skip bayless and max kellerman
and i was like you know this is
that's a small group of you know what
you can't like that
you can't let that define america you
also the narrative i don't like
is like oh that's white people not that
that what yeah i don't know those
[ __ ] that ain't
yeah yeah you thought that guy with that
buffalo mask on and his [ __ ] speedo
like that's not
we don't claim him yeah no i don't agree
i agree and
it was just chaos and just to have that
like uh we didn't see that until like we
see that in like foreign countries we
don't know we never changed
yeah they said they said last time they
saw this was when we was at war
and like the uh i forgot what war was
so just to bring this back and we have
like this in our own
backyard it's crazy not stuffed yeah
yeah i did not see that i mean was
filming a podcast when all this was
going down so just to go home i'm like
girl what happened
and just to see that yeah oh it was
while we were recording yeah yeah
yeah sure so yeah it was on oh well you
guys recording was on wednesday
no wednesday when was it wednesday or
thursday oh wednesday firing the kid
no [ __ ] i was editing and then
everyone's just popping and going do you
see that like what
yeah i got home and it was just chaos
yeah my girl texas just like holy [ __ ]
see what's going on at the capitol and i
get downtown too right
that's oh yeah it was crazy downtown
listen anywhere near where we're at
because i'm taking tigers
before it gets too [ __ ] crazy i'm out
bro they had like so many they had swat
like come down the street on la brea
it's like like 30 cop cars i'm telling
let white
black chinese portuguese viet
vietnam whatever the let them try to now
see what happens if any race tries it
again
without without that trump and him tell
him to do that
and pulling back the security let's see
what happens
i'm telling you try it again see what
happens shot in the face yeah well [ __ ]
now he's being investigated
i know and he's kind of like hold on
hold on now let me just come out here
with a speech
and you notice he even say joe biden
name in that speech he was like listen
let's just
let's just end it they won he won i'm
out of it so
you know i can't believe we're dealing
with this [ __ ] in 2021
yeah i think it's it's funny how and i
think i don't know
i think lebron james said he was like yo
it's funny how like people think that
and 2021 it was like it was a brand new
year now it's just a different day
it's the same it's just a different day
so the people yeah but you can't be like
oh
20 21's gonna be the same as 20 20.
otherwise i mean no one
would wake up in the morning or no one
be like yeah 20 20 was [ __ ] terrible
yeah
the worst year of our lives by far
correct so we've been alive i mean
if you talk some people from the 70s or
from world war two they're going to beg
the difference
but in our lifetime 2020 is the roughest
year so we can be like oh
20 21 something just like 2020. it's
like jesus christ dude
they don't then then don't play
basketball lebron or don't do this like
dog we got the only way we can move
forward is by hoping for the best
well that's it man we got the
vaccination dropping you got biden in
house so
you know you have the democrats you know
they own the senate they're in the house
now so
yeah you know all those changes you want
well here you go so if you think that's
the answer there you go i
i don't know i don't [ __ ] with buying or
trump i don't know but so
you have trump out of there which
divided the nation one way you look at
it so he's out you have the vaccination
like
we're impressed we're getting back to
normal yeah everything's happening too
because you're
you'll remember social media well social
media of course but
a lot of people don't have jobs you know
coronavirus the vaccinations
the economies and the [ __ ] dumps kids
can't go to school
so it's like everything's hiding right
now man no i don't even agree i agree
i get to sit back like 20 21's just like
2020 it's like dude
nobody has time for that man we gotta
march forward yeah
it's a lot well a lot of you know they
wasn't going to play the basketball game
yesterday well kyrie didn't he set out
because you know uh the the police that
shot jacob plate blake all of them got
like off no charges and uh that's a
dicey that's a tricky one
yeah and he was like i'm not playing he
didn't play that's that's
see but but every see if we weren't in
this heightened
like culture right now in that case
let's say that case happened 10 years
ago
those guys are playing basketball it's
like right now it's everything's so
intense
because if you look at that that case
it's tough man
it's it's tough to say not to play
basketball it's tough to say
that that was racist you know it's it's
[ __ ] we like the case like [ __ ]
dude it's just not good you know the one
he got shot when he come
uh came around close but he still he
survived but uh
he survived yeah but for from the fact
that that i know
i wasn't going to wisconsin yeah yeah
was that what you know no more
milwaukee what that is that is but so
you know
he has a uh i think it was a warrant
for his arrest but um something about uh
beating some girl yeah beat his girl
right so then uh
his girl has restarting order him
against them his girl called the cop
because he was there acting all crazy
trying to take take the kids or some
[ __ ] like that
so the cops come when they come he's
super hostile
they try to apprehend him tased him
three times just didn't work some people
don't respond to tasers you know that
some people just don't respond tasers so
then uh
his kid this is the this one the kids
the kids are in the car
he has a knife now there's here's where
it gets dicey there's no body camera
the knife was in the car and he's going
back to the car officers like stop or
i'm going to shoot
he keeps reaching for the knife now
here's where it gets dicey
they shot him i don't know 17 [ __ ]
times which way too much
way too much didn't 17 what were we
doing
yeah he was paralyzed yeah that was it
paralyzed now 17 meaning
like you won that's some kind of
different intention right there like 17
that's a lot but it was seven
it was seven shots just a lot of shots
yeah right there like point blank
yeah but i think so this is a narrative
that they were saying his kids was in
the car
right windows rolled up he was i'm going
to the car
because my kid i'm not about my kids is
in the car and he kept saying that and i
guess he was trying to get his kids like
roll the window down and whatnot but he
opened the door he had a knife in there
the police didn't wait shot him that's
the narrative that
that uh his family and everyone is uh
well here
but here's the problem so if a cop says
stop
and you you avoid the tasers you avoid
the yeah so who's who's responsible for
that
like who's that fallen that falls on
that falls on him mm-hmm
yeah but there's other ways we get like
is he like
for either party it shouldn't escalate
to that yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah i got you
yeah i feel you but like if you like if
like if let's say you weren't here today
and chapelle's like [ __ ] you hear the
cop shot like what the [ __ ] happened
like oh he's having issues with baby
mommy you know he has that let's just
call it like he has that restraining
order because he he beat her and [ __ ]
like that he had a felony
and he went back they're doing was
taking the kids and the cops pulled up
and they they [ __ ] told him to stop
and he [ __ ] talk [ __ ] to the cops
they tried to apprehend him dude he
evaded him
and then they tased him that [ __ ] didn't
work i'm like what the taser worked
nope and then three times he tried
teasing him like damn then what to do
then he was rushing back this car but
there's a knife and they're like
what yeah and then they should they
didn't know the knife was in there until
they shot him though
that's yeah that's that's not what i
heard i heard the knife is out oh that's
why
the problem is there's no body cam
mm-hmm exactly so
but there's like with this have
escalated to this
yeah he might have got beat up they
might have [ __ ] kicked his head in
but would he have been paralyzed if he
would have
stopped when they asked him to stop no
of course not but it's
so so who's responsible that's what like
my problem is
obviously he has a dark history with the
the felony and
the the the the wife put a restraining
arm
correct because he's a great guy correct
not because he's an awesome dad
yeah right so if you were to stop this
doesn't escalate to that
yeah i know i agree i agree promises the
cops
the did you need to shoot them 17 times
yeah that's where so it's like
everything's [ __ ] up
yeah that's what should have been shot
17 times he shouldn't have [ __ ]
even been in that position it shouldn't
escalate to that mm-hmm
so this seems like a constant battle
battle
but can we but we all can like i get it
it was
more of and during that climate where
like you know
this is during like the the uh george
floyd they know all right so this is
it's three of y'all versus him you
couldn't y'all could have tackled him or
something like that you could have
wrestled him but i think they tried nah
because he got
they tased him and they got up and he
walked around the car so a ca
the guy was following with the gun you
know what i mean so i i just it's just a
dicey situation
what i'm saying but excessive force uh
uh
is normally like met in that like like
i'm
what i'm trying to say i'm saying like
you shouldn't have that kind of force on
the guy
but remember so let's let's let's so we
don't know what if the knife was out or
not let's say the night let's put
yourself let your
a black cop or white cop doesn't matter
and you're in that situation
and you have let's say you have kids and
this dude has a
dark history man obviously you know a
rough
a rough going and there's a restraining
order and he's there for a reason the
tasers don't work
you want to go home and see your kids
you don't know this dude you know this
guy
is here for the cops are here for a
reason he's beat this
lady before and there's three kids in
the car and you have kids
he has a knife he has kids tasers didn't
work he has kids as well though
yeah but why are they there malik
because not because he's a great
guy yeah that's the problem there has to
be some
ownership here i got you on on the cops
for the excessive force what are you
guys doing
and then on him why are the cops there
white black chinese i don't give a [ __ ]
what color the cops are
why are the cops there they're kids
because he wasn't doing what he was
supposed to
by our constitution by our laws so it's
like the whole thing's a [ __ ] storm
yeah but at some point we got to sit
back and those cops white black chinese
they have families too correct they're
they're what they're trained to do which
is a whole nother thing maybe that we
should up the training what they're
trying to do didn't work
he has a knife i want to see my kids
okay so what were they you know what i'm
saying yeah now you have a set of skills
where you could have punched them knock
them out
i'm a set of skills like i apprehended
them took them down choked them out
they don't have those skills these are
guys that probably don't have much
experience in
combat they freaked the [ __ ] out yeah
but
you heard the text saying is bringing a
knife to a gun fight right
why would it so he let's say let's okay
i hear what you're saying now look at it
from this side so he has his kids in the
car
with the knife right he has a knife we
have guns
right he has to get close to you and
he's not all he's doing that
now all i'm saying is the guy said i'm
going in there
let my kids down it's dark windows now i
did see that he says tent
he said i'm just trying to my kids in
the back seat it's hot i'm trying to uh
open the door for my kids so they don't
suffocate so they have a knife inside
they got the officer follows him with
the the gun
behind him right proceeds to go behind
him he's like open up open it he opened
the door
the cop let off let's say okay a knife
in the car a knife in the car
you have a gun right who went up nine
times
ten out of ten a gun will beat a knife
you have to get close to the guy so i'm
basically saying like yo
this is the guy i said man f yeah i'm
going in i don't know that's what they
were saying on the tape man i'm going to
get my kids or whatnot so you go around
the car they got the officer follow him
now just take him for his word i'm
letting i'm letting the windows down
take the guy for his word yeah i'm just
saying i'm not taking i'm not taking
that guy for the buddy
if i take him for his word i'm there for
a reason
yeah i'm i'm not listening i'm not
trusting that guy that i'm there because
he beat his wife
yeah and there's issues with the kids
i'm not trusting when that guy goes
these cops already know what they're
there for
oh dude they're pulling up they pull up
the rap sheet
the cops aren't just rolling down the
street like oh there's a black guy yeah
the baby mama called because there's a
long history there's an issue of
violence
man it's stressful yeah that's the
toughest yeah it's nice but i'm saying
but in that climate i'm saying
george floyd and then what happened in
atlanta i know what are you doing phil
you're seeing them
what are you doing another situation
that all the nba players didn't play
because it was like man we tied to this
so just seeing just seeing that and just
like okay he has a knife
yeah right his is a tough example like i
said if it wasn't if
we weren't in these heightened times i
don't know if there's such an uproar
with his background
all right that's the case all right what
about because you know what you and
this is different but if let's say you
had a knife in the car and the cop told
you to stop
all right you're not gonna get my keys
i'm gonna do what the [ __ ] they tell me
to do dude yeah i'm gonna say hey
my kids don't call they're hot dude you
can so he was already
when he was walking through the car with
his kids they already did several times
it didn't work it's three guys right
and then that's the thing too like why
couldn't he just stop
because he kept saying my kids in the
car yeah because for one he didn't want
to be apprehended anyway
yeah i'll give you that
this is me being a white male my next
train of thought is
well that didn't work what else they
have guns yeah i'm gonna [ __ ]
stop yeah that's where i take ownership
if i keep doing this if i keep going
down this route and i know the history
of cops
and black guys i'm not gonna keep but
you're not gonna keep [ __ ] with these
i don't think
i get what you're saying like yo people
thinks like it's fair it's fast it's
that moment it's that moment
but think about him your father right
your kid is in the car you do whatever
it is
to get your kids no but here's the
difference now if the cops told me to
stop i'm gonna stop
because i know they have the capability
to shoot me in the [ __ ] face correct
um with this let me just let's say
let's let's say what was the best case
scenario of him fighting off those cops
what do you think's gonna happen what do
you mean like what was his end game then
his end game yeah would you so you you
were avoiding
so them trying to tase them avoiding the
tasers mm-hmm so
where did he think he was in guinness
car and just drive off nah nah nah what
was the plan
the plan was that i'm i'm going by his
work if he if he's
the cops are there to apprehend him
because his baby mom called
and later came out this baby mom was
like i didn't i called him but i didn't
really want to
that's kind of we'll get to that whole
baby she said hold on yeah
yeah i called them but i didn't want
them to do what to do what they did they
they well no no one wanted to get shot
correct i'm sure she didn't want him on
the property i'm sure
there's a reason why she has a
restraining order against him okay
all right again not because he's an
awesome dude okay yes
i got you but at the same time
so so be the dad doesn't give you
the right no no no being a dad doesn't
mean oh okay let's let him do it
no no but i'm look i'm taken as a father
like father stance right mentality right
so he has
my kids are in the car right so he
should offers like freeze and all that
so he
whatever he's like man my kids are in
the car the windows are rolled up
they they basically say you should have
thought about that like no free and so
he wrestled he wrestled with all and not
even wrestle they tased him first he was
like man my kids in the car so
if that's he goes around the corner
after the taste but you know all that's
not the way to
to so like to act of course we know
that's not yeah
we know that end game is not going to go
so i'm right or black i'm just saying
i'm just trying to
trying to figure out what led this to
seven shots point blank range
right so listen so he goes around the
knife then okay the knife is in the car
okay cool so the the knife in the car
tonight he's like man my kid's in there
and they're hot
right so he's like man f that so he's
doing whatever he can
to you know roll the window down get
this kid whatever right but you don't
give him that
opportunity cause you said i'm i have a
gun i'm trying to make it home to my
family and kids
i can't make that risk i can't make that
mistake so i follow him
and i shoot him point blank range seven
times in front of his kids it's just a
force right
of course so and after all that all he
said was i want my k
then the kids get out the car so you you
mean to tell me
that beginning he was like my kids in
the car and he was like man freeze and
all that man i'm not trying to hear that
my kid's in the car
so if the officer hear that yeah and are
the kids in danger
what do you mean like my kids are in the
car freeze you can't be like
all right but can someone let my kid out
that is would that not have been a
better way to handle it you know what
you do
communication skills but also malik
don't you think
him going there with these kids in
general already put them in a situation
it was a baby mama it was a baby mama
you know i like
babies those were her kids too yeah guys
we all have problems in the relationship
not to the black people i get what you
said never had a restraining order
my i've had no charges ever pressed
against me with any women i i get what
i'm just saying i'm just saying his
situation
yeah which is a big deal yeah because if
the cops get called to a house
for domestic violence they're not so
if there's domestic violence they're
taking the woman the woman's side
automatically
well no that's not fair someone has to
leave the situation yeah
so if you and your girl get in a fight
tonight and the cops can't one person
has to
it doesn't matter if your girl's like oh
i scratched his face one of you have to
leave correct every single time yeah
exactly bob said majority nine times out
of ten
the woman like they cater to the woman
my friend went through the same battle
he has
not as like restraining order but with
his baby mom called the police on him
he didn't do anything she had scratches
all on him he still went to jail
so he they call you you go to jail
that's the exception though
what do you mean you can't say oh he
didn't do anything
and relate it to this guy's story
because this guy did something well he
did do
you write so you're fine your friend
leaving that's the exception
no no most of the time there's an actual
problem they didn't he didn't leave she
called the cops and the cops came and
got him
that's why someone has to leave they
someone has something every time that's
the rule okay all right yeah
i'm saying in this situation she calls
the cops right so automatically you know
someone is going to jail right so
they're still there's the cops come
they're still arguing he was like man i
put these kids in the car
they get there i don't know i don't know
mo uh milwaukee's
like climbing but he said man i'm just
taking him for his word he said man my
kid's in the car
the windows are rolled up black tent i
know black 10 is hot
so he was like man my kids in the car
say taser he's like
you know black man off that man [ __ ] all
that my kid's in the car so he walks
around
and the guy officer follows him and you
can see in the video follows him
in the back like freeze freeze he opens
the door
excessive force for sure okay none of
this would have happened if you would
have just
followed directions i get what you're
saying but in that moment and it's
heightened like you said heightened
times and all this and you got to argue
with your baby mama you don't see
i get what you say i'm just taking
everybody everyone is acting reckless
including the cops
exactly including him so you so you're
probably thinking like man i even do
[ __ ]
you know i'm here to get my kids
whatever she tripping or something like
that whatever problems like that and
that's why she probably said well i
didn't mean
for him to go like that i didn't mean
him to get shot like that i didn't mean
you know what i mean so she's like
here's my question
the cops weren't pulling up they're
going oh we're gonna shoot this dude no
no because they don't they use the taser
and all that yeah i get what you're
saying but i'm saying this it was
nothing no no those actions led for that
man to get shot seven times
in front of his kids and he's basically
his main focal point was
my kids are in the car it's hot and it's
black tent i'm trying to get to my kids
make sure they're good first
take me to jail basically but i'll make
sure you know she said take me to jail
then i've done that nah but i honestly
didn't say that but i'm saying
he was like man i'm my first as a father
the kids are first
so hold on if the kids are first the
cops weren't being called
you wouldn't have fought with baby mom a
friendly kid we don't know why
we don't know what they fought it could
have been like some petty stuff like she
called the cops
man they do women do that i want to put
her situation on again he has a
background of this history yes of
violence
uh they said domestic violence and not
not child abuse or anything like that
hold up the domestic violence
yeah so you're not dealing with a guy
who has no blank history
yeah you're dealing with a guy who has a
rap sheet
so the cops are they know this pulling
up all right we got one here
you know what i'm saying like we got a
guy who has a history okay so they're
not gonna be that welcoming
they're gonna be like we're here for a
reason this guy has uh domestic violence
charges
correct he has a history of it correct
so i'm not coming i'm like hey man
everything all good no because
everything's not all good is that so
because we've been here before they
pulled up and it's the situation's
already heightened
they they came in on an argument so he's
already hot that she called the cops
i'm just putting it let's take those two
out of the concept right
let's double those people's situation
the guy that his back his background of
the man domestic violence hers is like
restraining order let's just take that
out of the situation
let's see a black couple arguing right
she calls the cops
right the cops come and everything is
all hiding he was like man my kid's in
the car
right he said i wanna hear that like
freeze get on bro
my kids are in the car so what do you
expect from him to do say officer my
kids in the car
can you just make sure they're good i'm
freeze i'm all at and see but you
but you're talking a straight
hypothetical situation now
because he said my kids are in the car
can you help me he never said that no he
didn't
he didn't he just said my kids are in
the car now now imagine if he didn't
have a rap shoot you didn't have
domestic violence
dude you're talking about a completely
different situation
you know what i'm saying yeah what's the
point what was your point as well no
i i just i'm good what were we gonna say
i was gonna ask malik uh so if you were
in that situation what would you what
would you done what
if i was that was you you're the guy you
would have [ __ ] with the cops oh no
listen i would
i get what he's saying i get what you're
saying i'm saying like as a father as a
black guy
mentality and and and i have a son or
whoever my kids is first
like i get it that's why i'm playing
your kids are first dude the cops they
you you want to escalate that situation
for them to be in that situation yeah my
kids aren't going to be
in that situation yeah because if i knew
the cops were coming and they're pulling
up
i'd tell baby mom well we're fine not
get the kids well we
how do we know that he knew baby mom
called the cops she she could be inside
the house on the phone with the cop we
don't know this
so what was what was there you give him
too much credit again what was their
sister
what situation they were arguing right
she called the cops right
now and now anyone if you call a cop so
why would he stay
so no no no did she call the cops
because she was in fear of him
hitting her again i think he hit her i
don't know i don't know the context of
it it's too it's too difficult but
there's been a history before where he
has
yeah that's what i'm saying like i don't
know if she you're not going in a
situation where it's just all
good no you're going to situate where
there is a history there
all right i'm just okay so i'm saying
i'm just trying to put everyone in
my if my if my first priority is my kids
one if the if she goes i'm calling the
cops i'm not loading my kids up in the
[ __ ] car and trying to get out of
there before they pull up
all right kids are going to stay here
the cops coming all right let me let me
talk to them
all right i'm just saying i know i know
those baby mama sit you i don't know him
but i have friends around
that that could have been easily like
one of my partners right and i'm just
saying
they are very they love their kids they
love the kids they have baby mama drama
they do
yeah i know they they i know it's like
difficult and i love black women but
they're they're very difficult on my
friend they're horrible look at that
chin
yeah here's what we know about khanisha
uh what can issue please police are
called
who complained there was a violation of
restraining order so he's not supposed
to be there at all yeah she had a
restraining order against them
police tried to arrest him but have said
that taser win was ineffective and
neighbors video shows blake walking away
from options and get into a vehicle with
his children's side
uh she shot him at close range was on
lake was armed with a knife
when do we find oh drop the knife
uh shows a grain object in blake's hand
the man who shot the video said he
didn't see
a knife yeah so do we think the cops are
making up dropping
no there's a we know there's a knife so
blake was armed with a knife and
resisted an arrest
uh said that same guy but the the guy
said who shot the video said we didn't
see a knife no no no
well that you're talking about the
neighbor yeah the cop said and then but
then you just said
i did see a knife okay uh one bite said
bill kendrick
dropped the knife like he was armed with
a knife and resist an arrest
said the guy keep scrolling down uh
blake's family attorney have said the
shooting left him paralyzed from the
waist down bullets pierced his abdomen
shattered some of his vertebrae
severed his spinal cheek but he's at
home all right
blake had no previous criminal record
blake is serving two years probation
after reaching a plea agreement
on charges without an attempt to arrest
him um so he did there was an
active felony warrant for his arrest at
the time what does that mean no
yeah what does that mean blake had been
charged a month earlier with third
degree sexual assault
felony and two misdemeanors trespassing
and disorderly conduct
in connection with altercation with his
girlfriend's home several weeks
earlier under his deal with the
prosecution blake pleaded guilty to two
misdemeanor accounts of disorderly
conduct
involving domestic abuse
so there was a little bit of background
there all right
it's a tricky situation yeah and that's
the scariest i think the cops should
obviously excessive force for sure
exactly and i'm i'm not
again it wouldn't have got my point is
it wouldn't have gotten there yeah
if you know yeah otherwise you have a
knife why is it
i don't know knife yeah but you don't
you don't it doesn't like
of course you don't i don't feel happy i
feel excited all i just i get upset when
you when you see
your own kind get gunned down hold up i
don't what do you mean no one's happier
excited
no no one's excited no no i mean i'm
just saying like yo it's not
i guess the feeling is different because
you feel like yo that could be either
one of my friends and stuff like that
you don't it's not
that's not great and i would hope yeah
and god will
hopefully it never happens yeah but
tonight if you and your girl are
fighting
if she hits you and the cops are called
i would pray to god that you're smart
enough
where you're not going to resist arrest
and grab a knife no of course not
no no no no i'm not saying that i'm just
saying excessive force that's
uh with all that situation all that went
down your main point is the excessive
force
seven shots seven shots we didn't even
know he was gonna be alive
yes seven shots kind of that's kind of
tough for sure
and that's all i'm saying it's like yo
what did that again what i'm saying is
it wouldn't even
gotten to that point if he didn't listen
if you would have just played by the
rules
it it it is some videos where guys do
play by the rules
and then they like still get like
excessive force for sure
that's the exception yes exception if we
based everything off the exception dude
our society would be [ __ ] yeah
jesse versus ferguson real quick
question for you guys
since you guys are huh i'm just saying
just uh going oh did you guys are black
have you had history with cops
being like [ __ ] to you guys nah
not the white ones the black ones are
the [ __ ] i've i've had i've had a
black one
[ __ ] go home because it was and i
like to pop off
it boys was like that and then if the
white cop was like
chill like kind of like he was looking
at he was looking at the black cop like
hey man yeah like he was just like why
the [ __ ] you leave the house like that
like why why
what what the [ __ ] you doing out here
like just so aggressive i'm like listen
i'll answer any
i'm not like trying to and it's like
weird because like you you
you feel like so startled because
especially if you don't think you do i
was riding a bike
you know i was just riding over riding a
bike yeah i was just riding a bike
you know so like phoenix yeah that's
back home in phoenix and he was just so
[ __ ] aggressive about it now grant
i've had i've had a you know
a white cop do the same thing she
thought i was um
robbing an atm when i was depositing
cash oh my god yeah
and she was like um and she she wouldn't
even she wouldn't even look at my id
i had everything all my info like i
lived down the street from the bank that
i was
uh banking at but she was just like she
was like you look sketch
you look like you're before she kept
saying you look sketch and i'm like
listen i have all the information like
seat yeah i have a receipt she was like
i need to see if the girl in the car is
okay and
you know my homegirl was like you know
was like yo like he's trying to give you
his information
you know he's trying to you know you
know comply with you but you're just
being rude to him
you know what i mean eventually she you
know she just stopped after
you know she checked on my home girl but
i was like like i'm sitting here with my
information ready to give it to you you
know what i mean
so it's such she should lose her job
yeah yeah it's like she shouldn't have a
job you look sketch what the [ __ ]
no no you know like you know not to uh
overtake your story but you know the
the head of security for the the capital
like the three head of securities all
lost their jobs
really yeah they all got fired i mean
rightfully i mean you got
one job to protect the capital and they
[ __ ] took it over
yeah i mean it's it's tough man like i
said i've had
yeah both be really and then i've had a
cop be really really cool with me
you know what i mean the times i've had
been you know
i've interacted with with cops but i
mean it's it's just so
[ __ ] yeah a lot of them are like
you know power hungry man their egos are
insane like some became cops because
maybe
you know they're [ __ ] within school
and stuff like that and they just got
their respect would you like to
should not no they should not be not
become cops correct
and that's where you know with the
defund things a little
it gets a little dicey because if you
want to have a
vetting process and get better cops you
can't take money from that yeah
if you want better people and better
cops you got to give them more resources
and also how to get rid of those shitty
ones yeah because 98.9 percent of them
are
great [ __ ] people yeah but that again
that one percent that's
that's that's the majority but then they
they get painted with the same brush
exactly and also i don't think i like
there's a lot there
they give cops too much to do
like bro it's like it's like we don't
want to deal with domestic why did the
cop have to pull me over for riding a
bike
yeah mm-hmm but like comment when
there's an argument
cop's like listen dude we want to
[ __ ] go get criminals
we don't want to figure out you know who
hit who this argument here right like
you guys need a [ __ ] therapist
yeah send a specialist dude no i agree
everyone needs a little love everyone
yeah i mean yeah
i know i'm getting all jittery
speaking of i just think about those
situations and you just like yeah
yeah there's no right ans i mean it's
[ __ ] tough climate man
no yeah yeah and you ask any like any
actually any of your black friends like
what's their run in with a cop
they all have a story yep and that's the
thing about it and that's what i think
that
uh what athletes say is two two
different sides of america
it's like we deal with like the side
where
you see excessive force and stuff like
that but also i i've been in with some
white cops that have been dope
dope as [ __ ] yeah dope as well i don't
have anything against the cops but i'm
just saying like it's
i've seen it and i've been certain
people that are yeah
and it's just like the other side where
it's just like let me see a license to
registration
all right cool and it's the other side
where let me see license registration
i'm gonna reach for it no free
and all that yeah so the problem the
promise when we when we just
group oh all cops are racist all cops
are bad people no they're not
exactly that's like if you if you met a
comic comic let's say you came to the
comedy store and he was [ __ ] terrible
like dude all comics
[ __ ] [ __ ] that one guy that one
interaction had the majority were
[ __ ] off correct oh it's like
the thing when people say all comics are
depressed yeah yeah you just hear that
one [ __ ]
no not all comics are depressed yeah the
selfies have some dark [ __ ]
life is good yeah but it's easy to lump
everyone in yeah it's easy to like lump
that and it's like no
not everyone's depressed nah sorry this
is a heavy topic
no i mean it's it's gonna be times right
it's heavy times it's capitals just got
[ __ ] rated
yeah no it's it's it's going to 2021
and this manner is just crazy now you
know everyone is
again everyone is on edge now there's
like man get trump they call it a trump
head and i was just like
that's what 13 days left so
and then now it's a narrative now it's
like look well look look what they did
like you said it was just a small group
of people
that's like you know went crazy they
don't represent any
republicans or anyone who voted for
trump like that there's a small
group of [ __ ] morons yeah but i do
it's like saying isis represents muslims
yeah yeah you know
or the the italian mob represents
italians
they're a they're a [ __ ] fraction
dude
those are just [ __ ] extremists oh
yeah yeah
yeah today yeah yeah yeah 12 days get my
days mixed up well you know what i
appreciate that we could have the
[ __ ]
yeah dialogue yeah and not [ __ ] you
know even though
we're trying to yeah i mean we're all
just trying to figure the [ __ ] out no
one has to fight
i don't think anybody wants anyone
anybody shot like yeah
white black no one tries to write
anything it's just
especially in front of their kids yeah
that whole situation is [ __ ] up i know
when i heard that i was like all those
[ __ ]
jobs yeah yeah be there any way could
have done something
everybody's feeling something
everybody's feeling it
you know seriously when you see the
situation everybody feels so it's not a
great situation it's not a great
situation hopefully [ __ ] calms down
i don't know what else trump can do to
fire rally up his troops there
she don't know what else they can do is
because now everyone's gonna
kind of be on guard you know no
seriously and but he's also gonna be
held
responsible for whatever happens crap i
bet you see him chill the [ __ ] out oh
he's chilled before you saw that press
hey this guy wanted me to talk about his
situation let me explain it on uh
fighter and the kids
uh love advice all right well let's do
that okay okay sweet uh sex
i'm just saying uh oh like oh what's up
should we put these i don't put them on
on screen just don't say the games did
anybody hit you up about when did we do
it last monday
yeah yeah people hit them up were they
glad about it or were they pissed they
happy they're happy that i was like bro
i need you to hold on yola look get get
him off the stage
well he's nuts why'd you send
oh gosh dr love dr love what the [ __ ] is
up
aggressive got a bit of a story for you
today i don't know what to do about it
i'm 28 married for 10 years he got
married at 18.
yeah we've seen divorce she stayed in
miami started an
old fans okay i went back to seattle to
be my friend
to be to be by my friends and family yo
life is great now i can't even believe
how
good things are going compared to when i
was with that [ __ ]
damn all right i don't think so yeah
right
sounds like you're still [ __ ] hurt
since we were married last year we did
our taxes together so my stimulus check
went straight to her
she's keeping it also i was praying for
her and is
it does this end by them asking us for
money yeah no it says no no no
all right i was paying for her and her
dad's phone bill which they just dipped
out of
got new lines and phones leaving me with
an old bill and two extra
phone payments we can just stop those
though you know
mal what do i do i'm not rich i bike for
uber eats oh he bites this [ __ ] to stop
ruining everything i work for
a fighter [ __ ] ass nate diaz style
just kidding but for real
do i just let it go do i send her only
fans to her grandma
what's gucci dr love let me know
heartbreak emoji
uh i he's still upset yeah a lot of
anger
a lot of anger i'm still confused what
he's asking yeah i don't know
let what go yeah he just he's just named
it's over start only fans i
would let her phone lines go you only
just call team over like hey i don't
know
her and her dad like why would you play
her and her dad like phone line
you know and you drive for uber you bike
for uber you didn't even say drive
nice but he said he's sick of giving her
money
yeah no this is an awful submission
bubba yeah i mean there's not that we
can't do it i don't know
i i don't i just don't get there's no
problem here all right let's move on did
they break they broke
up and he just dude just stopped paying
for a phone line leave her alone there
we go
what's up dr love uh i need your help so
look
me and my ex date for a little over
three years we've now been broken up for
the past five months i really do miss
her
we talk here and there but i don't know
if she feels the same what can i do nah
boy
i dm them back i said what are you doing
yeah he's like they're both 21 years old
what you thinking it's not puppy love
yeah
how long did you say they were getting
it uh i think he said three years
yeah three years three years little over
three years we broke up five months ago
yes probably his first major breakup
yeah of course just don't know how to
get over it
so i honestly i think that you should
start slanging dick dude yeah
quick you're 21 dawg that is true yeah
yeah
hold on put that put it out there though
you dropped it on the table drop it on
the [ __ ] table let them know
you 21.
do what kanye did guys girls who gives a
[ __ ] right
i mean he went through a kardashian
first yeah yeah let him get a
cardinality
damn right he's 21.
no guys girls yeah plants what but also
it is the new year
2021. start fresh start fresh do what
you do you know
put that thing out there bro anyone dude
that's all he know for like three over
three years that's all you know is this
girl's routine
you know i mean i get it like yo he's
like breaking that bond and she probably
flourishing she's 21 fresh meat and i
mean a relationship
i mean uh i'm a fresh queen uh
yeah and she said fresh meat
is
um no i just think that you should you
know she flourishing though
so don't worry about it i don't know we
gotta see what she looks like but also
they still
talk yeah that's
[Applause]
yeah quit talking yeah give it time dude
yeah because she
know all she knows is like routines
women love routine
consistency right so yeah they're 21 bro
yeah
i mean what's your routine but but you
know are they in college
you know they're just trying to figure
this [ __ ] out man these people these
kids are growing up fast
we all know yeah we both see you okay
see what i'm saying
you know so i'm like listen doing drugs
different jobs
[Applause]
and she now she's hooking up with your
dad now what did you did you write back
back to him no i said uh i i just gave
him the courtesy we
just discussed it on the show oh god i
got it yeah got it okay so hey
man move on chappelle says slang it
brendan said brendan said man
guys i'm saying you block her don't fall
on instagram get out of sight out of
mine exactly
oh he's got a blocker oh yeah he can
just not talk to her not a blocker oh
you can mute her on instagram
and twitter so you don't have to
unfollow i don't want to see it
you don't see any of it yes you don't
want to be
you know patty yeah you don't but at the
same time yo
okay yeah what is yeah what if she's out
with some other dude that's what i'm
saying yeah you don't want it
yet blocked when you're at home watching
live flicks crying she's on a date at
least on social media i feel like text
is different
that's what i do do stop all forms of
communication
move on yeah you gotta you gotta move on
i'll never forget on snapchat
my my ex like oh snapchat
i was following this back then i was
like we was fresh off at like five like
him
like five months like man i saw one of
them snapchats and i saw like her and
like the passenger side and he had like
a little bmw like kind of
and i saw his like arm with number
tattoos i was like
that's not her that's not her friend
hell yeah that's not her friend
she don't even listen to rap music like
that music loud and she just showing her
little thighs
i was like oh my stomach hurt i couldn't
eat for three days yep damn did you
did you stop following her hell yeah
yeah yeah that's amazing you don't need
the reminder but you don't need to
remind
listen brother 21 here stop it now
unfollow her before you see that that
scarred me all right
good luck yeah exactly and it's the last
one right here
here we go dr love i need some help so
my girl and i have been dating for over
seven months
now but before me she was in a five-year
relationship so i find out just recently
over the holidays
her and her birthday which was a couple
days before christmas she's been talking
her exes
on from what it seemed like it was
meaningless conversation
that she didn't initiate so naturally i
get upset not because of her talking to
whoever but because i believe
i deserve some sort of communication
from her about it
of course she ends up getting mad and
what seemed kind of defensive but she's
saying
that she's upset because i asked her
what was up and she didn't want to tell
me
anything at first because to her was
important didn't have anything to do
with her
uh but i insisted and kept that she was
upset i got a certain type of way with
her after she let me know and in her
eyes that was wrong with me
so now i've been going on uh going days
trying to apologize make things right
but nothing
at the same time she shouldn't it like
she should be comfortable to just
explain it engage if it's
nothing yeah then like defense the being
defensive about it
makes you something like this how do you
find out
yeah what do you say how do you find out
he said uh so naturally
yeah but he didn't say yeah she's been
talking yeah because that yeah maybe
maybe she was close with the aunt and
that was like hey happy holidays like
giving me something stupid which is fine
but like
at the same time it's her birthday as
well yeah yeah he could chill on the
insecurity a little bit but
at the same time she could just [ __ ]
be like yo
yeah that's community i'm tight with the
i love the um
[ __ ] him that was cool i don't [ __ ] with
him yeah i don't [ __ ] with that dude but
the aunt is cool
but it could be her her her ex texting
from his own phone i did that a couple
of times
hey you know you know malik think about
you all the time and just he still got
the little sweater you wear
boy him he wear it all the time oh for
real that's me texting all the time like
you know when you go come and see him
and all that other yeah come see us god
damn dude
i've not done ever never i came from my
wife
text me i'm like you texting me i came a
long way that's what i'm saying yeah
yeah yeah well you're rising up all
right rising up and listen
on your aunt's phone
let me see what she's doing she
responded because i'm still on block
i don't know i'm doing this check it out
check out this picture of mountain
shirt off by the beach though he looked
good yeah
this is somehow so silly look at this
dick pic
wait now it's so crazy
you say look at this big
you're gonna fight another dick like
that you're a real trooper man
yeah he's had a real problem lately
girls are scared of that big daddy
we feel bad i heard you were really good
with it
that's one thing about it
he's really down right now
i'll never forget bro i was like you're
a different man now i was a different
man
yeah i went through but again i i'm able
to
express my vulnerability to like people
because i was in a
place you were there i was there i was
at a low level i remember i was at the
comedy store and i was so mad that
justin pulled me to the side he pulled
me in
was that corn canters or cornies or
whatever corners
carnies corny's and he just like listen
listen man
listen you look out here no haircut you
look at you you look awful
all right now you going over this girl
like she she beating you down you
you signed up for open mics look at you
no shave like you look
horrendous now listen i'm gonna tell you
to do get a new look
get a new look and just start loving
yourself that's what justin said he was
like
if he said like get a new look he's like
if i look like you i guarantee you man
please
oh yeah cause you you he used to roll
around in a do-rag to the open mics
him and slippers i didn't know yeah he
was sad
he had no fashion or nothing nothing he
was sad i was how long was that like six
months ago
what wait what that was that was around
uh no hold on because that was a joke
right there no
is it no it's a goddamn joke no hell no
you're like oh no you
i don't think you understand nah i was i
was going through she beat me down
britney
she beat me down but i know at the same
time show up like that you got to get
these jokes off
even sad you still at home i got to work
on my set but uh
hey man just listen i'll text girls hey
man i text girls from my
you know from my uh my ex and it's so
stupid because she engaged with the
conversation oh
[ __ ] she's like yeah you think it's the
aunt who's really cool
damn malek's so stressed out now you get
this new job he's making all this money
he's worried to come after his money he
says you're like
texas he was like y'all had this special
bond he felt like yo y'all started
together
you said you were the one now he's
making all this money he's worried that
the right girl won't come along
he said he'd make all his money he's
still got that central though because he
want to be frugal with his money
he didn't give up the wrong look oh wow
oh yeah no straight out of the wire yeah
[Applause]
he
new york on vh1 you know the main guy
who always had a do-rag on
the little mustache
you know he is that's a good one you
look just like chance though and he had
a brother that had like yeah
to the new rack he had a picture he does
yes or the flavor of uh new york
whatever
damn he had a durag man by the way oh
he's um
he's bisexual is he yeah the one with
long hair is i think
nah nah chances chantis yeah how you
know that man type it in he just came
out with that
well it says it on his ground i don't
see no do-rag though
so he's you want to see if he's bisexual
yeah
i'm trying to tell you he like bro it
came up hey i was by
i was by your side during those times so
i didn't know he was going through it
look any we
we need a bisexual show hold on
we need a bisexual show we did have a
bisexual show what's your
i think he's coming because he he came
out he said dear dudes and uh
on ladies look ladies look who's back in
sega's last chance romance our fave
aka chancellor newer series he's trying
to sing right
if you think you takes uh case there's
nothing about dude signing up for that
oh you wanna go to instagram the last
where did you see that i saw that i said
oh no probably are you locating him
right now no
no he can't he came out he came out
saying um
yeah what's his instagram i don't know
she wouldn't put that like oh yes let's
get a bisexual show i think he came out
that uh i think you want him out i don't
know
all right well i apologize well i mean
look it up look at those pictures you
can just tell
nah man all right i apologize i look
like you were braids dog
oh those don't do that i'm just saying
look at matt shut up look at malik
that dude that jesus
she's not looking at the improv open mic
going through my lips [ __ ] up am i
right
is michael michael
y'all cut my mic is that my time is that
my sorry
i think maybe his brother it would be
the one in the dude with that long hair
yeah there it is that's
that's a solid geez yeah that's so funny
if just like change your look yo i did
not know you look like that shout out to
justin for
really helping you out yeah yeah like i
said i was supportive dawg
he was yeah i was just like i don't know
he was going through it i was going
through it i was like this guy
can't tell by the dude
yeah one second oh my god jesus well you
look good now
yeah i appreciate it's better yeah much
better i i relate to dude with that
auntie phone
damn yeah well hey yeah tell her to
chill out
hey jay goes what what are you doing for
our kelly's birthday today
i know he did it jay
all right um okay so this was
submitted by spectral22 on instagram
there were a bunch of rumors the other
day about kanye west and
the makeup guru jeffree star having an
affair and that's the reason why he's
leaving
kim kardashian here's and that's the
problem with this is the
the source came from is a girl got
famous on tick tock for licking toilets
during covet
yeah so that's it yes she was
the source and what ended up happening
so this video went viral
she lit toilets yeah um and what ended
up happening was that she
was saying that she had a really good
source that she's friends with a lawyer
who gave her all the details she
couldn't drop any receipts yet
but that the reason why jeffree star
like lived in calabasas was because the
kardashians then when
kanye went to wyoming he went to wyoming
shortly after there were a bunch of
these little things that made people
yeah speculate a bunch of different
things where they would go through
jeffree star's instagram account look
through like twitter
his twitter was pretty wild too yeah
jeffrey stars from like 11 years ago i
think because he used to say things
like he was like last night was fun
kanye yeah and then he started deleting
stuff
like that yeah he was saying like oh
kanye likes bright lipstick because he
likes the way it looks on his nuts
but uh he played into that because he
later released a video kind of hyping it
up saying
like he's gonna address the rumors about
kanye and he came out and said
that's not real like this is all fake
i don't know kanye i've never met him
this and that whatever
and the girl came out afterwards and her
friend got an
audio clip the girl who came out with
that tick tock said look at that toilet
yeah who licked the toilet said that she
made it all up because she wanted to
blow up basically here's the thing
here's the thing about that too so
if kanye wanted to if jeffree star
wanted to they could smoke
the [ __ ] out girl yeah defamation 100
i wouldn't this is the clip of person
that she lied about it
did they know i was obviously going to
expose myself because what i did was
just
too legendary you know really not even
getting sued
i made this entire scandal up there is
literally not one bit of truth to
anything i have said i just tripped the
entire world into talking about me again
because i was on a lot of adderall on
board
that girl has three more minutes of fame
how do we let these people exist
it's crazy it's insane she's mentally
unstable
yeah she's just you know she's trying to
extend her 15 minutes of fame as long as
she can damn
but yeah she gets in trouble man gets
sued like a [ __ ] for defamation
yeah big time if connie's like hey this
affected my tour sales
she has sued for millions doesn't have
the money i got yeezys on right now i'm
contemplating
but he he could still sue her yeah oh
yeah yeah absolutely especially with
this audio of her admitting to doing it
yeah yeah
if they want to i'm sure kanye's like
one i don't care he's too but he i made
over a billion dollars i don't care what
they say about mm-hmm
and jeffree star said it wasn't true
either yeah he also said it wasn't true
i guess he was kind of [ __ ] around
with the fact that people thought it was
true so he would like
delete dms that he said like oh it was
fun
hanging out last night kanye west so a
lot of people thought he was trying to
hide it
but that kind of helped him hype up his
video saying that nothing ever happened
yeah yeah i'll play his thing six and
allegedly i'm sleeping with kanye
let me just say this one time for any
news outlet uh
i like very tall men me and kanye uh
have never hung out and this whole thing
is really funny so
i guess if this is a start to my new
year
happy new year okay so anyway uh that
was it
yeah what i'm just saying so sad what
you gonna say dawg
you see him come through with the nails
like that he said
i've never hugged you what
jeffree star been around a lot of black
women let's just get that out
and the fact that like yo i didn't i
thought i just heard about jeffree star
because i guess he was
had like a a black boyfriend and oh so
basketball
basketball was a basketball player in
germany yo
and i was like yeah okay i didn't know
jeffrey still i didn't know jeffrey
star's worth like a hundred million
dollars
i didn't know that he said and then i
was like okay
maybe this basketball player didn't like
that kind of goes
more into there is like a whole thing a
lot of people think that was a publicity
stunt that he did because there are
other allegations against him who the
star
oh allegations oh cause he's saying the
n word no
what uh okay this is all alleged because
i
have heard that he is suing quite a few
people people for talking about this
but allegedly he has had
situations where back in the day he got
famous off of myspace
he was a musician and a lot of people
who he used to hang out with
people that was in his band got caught
allegedly with underage girls and he has
allegations that he
did similar things with underage boys
gotcha
so a lot of people thought that that
fake basketball player thing
was him faking a relationship to make it
to
take away from that whole case are they
are they still together
no like they've done a big like public
breakup and that's why people thought
that's what's happening yeah is he still
under investigation or something
i believe so yes damn there's like it's
really
sketchy from what i've looked into this
is all a legend again i would like to
say
um because there are people coming out
saying that like they've been paid hush
money
and people retracting statements well
you can't you can't come out if you was
paid hush money that's the whole thing i
know
somebody no there was somebody allegedly
who got paid hush money
then started reaching out to other
people who are gonna say something
saying if you recant he will also pay
you those people didn't take it
and now they're trying to say like oh
he's trying to
pay people off okay allegedly messi
messi
um okay so people are clowning lil bow
wow again oh because
he was on a boat he posted a video of
him and some friends on
this boat okay
i want you guys to see this video okay
play the video please why didn't you do
this
[Applause]
look at him tight okay they can't move
a nice day on the on the boat on the
water with his friends he posted this
onto instagram and people
started to clown what did they say and
so a few
hours later he did another video
wait keep going down keep going down
keep going down
thank you bro
they basically shamed him into getting
another ball
he was like damned yeah look at him now
i know he was like man [ __ ] y'all i
wonder if the girls are like wait why
are we getting off the boat he's like
cuz man we need a bigger one
they probably were showing them like
dial look
the fact that the girls rolled with him
on that little boat hell no
have you been on the boat shout out to
the dudes it looks like it's on a
trailer though doesn't it doesn't look
like it's in the water
yeah it looks like this car is passing
by yeah
you said the shadow is his homie yeah
recording oh yeah
yeah from the dog
we're only going to be like 30 seconds
big dawg that's all we need [ __ ]
that bro what would it can you go up i
want to see the jokes
i want to see the jungle scroll down
pulled up in the ss
titanic
live your [ __ ] life man bro
dawg that's so funny bye wild challenge
edition yo [ __ ] what was that what was
that boat
uh in rush hour to where he was like she
was like what's the name of your boat oh
man bro but he's so funny to bob while
telling she's just
i say keep doing it keep trolling he
said
the first one he's [ __ ] up the first
one i think he he didn't mean to troll
and then he played as a troll because
everyone called him out on it
yeah so he's just playing people no he
actually tried to post a picture of him
in it
hilarious i say keep doing it yeah vow
i'll live your [ __ ] life his next one
got to be like
was that both so small by the way he
wasn't just [ __ ]
look at his friends all right
hey you know this homie reminded me of
and uh uh the chappelle showing that
dude always be doing
the robots
he can't even move his arm
yo bro that's so funny though great
i respect it better i'll be me on one of
these fans
just getting it
okay so childish burrito on instagram
wants you to react to the actor
the mountain is getting into the fight
career
i say go for it the guy in game of
thrones have you watched the game no i
haven't seen him
oh yeah i say get he's always he has the
body which one is it but he he's just so
big
one with the gloves right there i just
giant guy i just think he's huge
he's so big strongest man at one point
and he's i think he's
i haven't seen his speed though super
slow okay i mean
do you need to see it holy [ __ ] but he's
big though like who's
is that his girl yeah she's tiny too
look at terry crews
man you're incredible brother
he's so big yeah dude look at let's see
his boxing video
where is he from iceland iceland yeah
he's taking it so he's a south pole
oh hold on
oh hell no
this is when he probably just started
huh looks so slow though yeah
honestly
yeah i don't think he should where's
this fight who's he fighting though it's
all with that
yeah i know everyone wants to do it now
everyone wants to fight me everyone's
trying to fight
lo jake and logan shook the game i'd
assume if his acting curve is going
better he wouldn't be doing this
he has actually has a movie with mike
tyson did uh mike tell you about that
i saw the trailer let's move on i saw
the trailer as well
what was it bad
can we play the trailer real quick about
mike tyson acting and
you're probably just hating all right
well is it mike tyson and just put thor
uh what's that i can't type a new movie
maybe yeah
yeah oh that's it that's probably good
y'all just taking it okay all right tell
us what you think
all right let me watch it for myself
okay oh shut up that's what we're doing
take a bite yeah go ahead take a bite of
your cookie
don't be afraid get the [ __ ] out of here
it was like mike can you turn a little
faster okay okay
listen i bet the action parts are really
good
[Laughter]
that little turn that little turn
can we give the action part it was like
and now mike
mike can you be stuff you're acting mike
well that's what that's supposed to do
it's tough huh i literally thought you
were just talking i was like mike's
probably leave them alone they diss
people i was like oh [ __ ] mike come on
he's like where's your money and you're
gone
i'm not your friend i was like damn mike
is his brother really like that
yeah uh yeah he had a stroke oh [ __ ]
because he's 700 pounds
he's a big guy damn but it's uh it's
temporary so it'll it'll come and go
belle's palsy oh bill's part yeah so
unfortunately for filming
when he filmed it i guess that's when it
was going up yeah
it flared up
he was talking regular then he came
to stop doing that right now just stop
doing it right now listen
i'll go see it because the action scenes
are probably dope as far as i can go see
it you mean you're going to get it
because it's going straight oh they want
to say it's not going
to say go see what you think
they can't even get wonder woman in that
[ __ ]
in the [ __ ] mountain
worth the money and goat talk about yeah
that might be a good date night for me
my girl
i still go see i like the action to
watch it on your [ __ ] cell phone
he's like i'm gonna go see did you like
you got served i love you the acting was
horrible but the dancing was great
that's different though you see what i'm
saying
that's like the same thing here they're
not doing it for a little saint
listen what else you got jim
all right thank you dog i appreciate it
that's [ __ ] up you left them hanging
yeah you love me
i've left you hanging before i'm sorry
it's a new table yeah a new table
you know of singer right oh yeah yeah so
they're making a
i guess a one-off all-terrain porsche
wow
it's for like a long-term cost uh client
that they had jesus christ
that thing can't be cheap let's see
there's a guy who has all trained
porsche already though really
yeah famous uh why the why
god damn that's good
[ __ ] that's cool oh wow oh sorry
holy [ __ ] and they're only making one
uh two for this client goddamn two two
one-offs
yeah so they're not you can't like order
it i don't think so now
i think can't be cheap that thing is so
sick would you get it
i would love one of those yeah with the
wheels and all that 59 backhand yeah i
think
sick and all right this is old footage
of kanye west
rapping and his tooth flew out are you
serious wait
probably getting off this is probably
post accident yeah this is through the
wire days
my stack said i'm so broke i look back
like damn was i on crack i mean 12
platinum changes i own that
what the hell is wrong with me now sing
along with me even though i dropped out
yo my two fell off man yeah oh nearly
laughing he laughing
oh my god yo glc
people say i got an attitude
one thing about when you start
freestyling start somebody start rapping
your head stop don't
don't stop moving to the verse is over
with bro i love that he kept going
but i didn't know that i didn't know he
was uh too many p's kanye too many
words he was getting off a little bit
even though that was written it wasn't a
freestyle
that was written i think i mean you guys
have to have stuff in your head
too right yeah some stuff yeah but i
mean
yeah back in those days ludacris used to
be like off the top like he was the like
only
please it's very rare that someone's off
the top what do you mean
you rap city to the basement these guys
just be freestyling off the top i'm
nowadays oh no no but i'm talking about
the best guys too huh like
and especially famous yeah i think
they're go a lot of people oh no
no because it's nice remember drake's
first freestyle on funk flicks
was it bad it was awful yo but how long
ago was that though that was
when he first pre-drilled black
blackberry pre-drake with the size
uh ovo bro no not even ovo yet y'all
like the ovo hoodie
oh yeah you got a new line she's the
gents
jesus bruh yeah that's no do-rag
what else you got jen this is a little
if this went viral this white dude
calling the
black guy the n-word constantly he's
just a douche bag oh i've seen this in
this
oh my god knocks him out yeah yeah i'll
show you [ __ ]
does he oh in a gas station in a gas
station
oh this is dope and he's this guy's like
holding it together
two blocks away how about 80 crazy no
it's crazy
i'm gonna walk to you i'm gonna walk
right to my house for you bro
oh god i'm not trying to disrespect
we messed up what
credit to him not yours buddy
you got yours buddy
okay he's okay okay
okay good okay
good good you're good you're good you're
good
you're good you're good
well he crawled down to all fours yeah
all boots most wanted
he sounded black before that fight
didn't turn white okay okay okay okay
i drive to my house to see you bro i'm
like oh okay then he got hit with that
yeah he was like oh whoa the white came
out hey
hey ohio yeah as soon as i walked in
standing with his friends i was assuming
and calling the employees two black guys
the n-word
wow oh he was calling employees yeah and
then that guy was in line
he's like yo you need to quit out on
that man
yeah that's a good girlfriend was like
that's what you get you get
buddies buddy yeah that's what you get
buddy you got yours but yeah
that's such a ohio rough you got yours
buddy you got yours
yeah and one limped in iced tea or what
um
that's with alcohol oh twisted teeth
yeah
oh boy he smacked up [ __ ] out i just get
hit with that [ __ ]
bro that can he came with he came with
power
yeah bro he should have never kicked me
listen he was going to pick it up he's
like all right man his wife yeah
but he killed did you notice he flipped
it
it's a racially motivated one too though
all right what's that girl that um
this girl right here no not that one
give me one sec okay
no the first one
no this one area okay
they call her soho karen she's like 20
22 years old and she
accused a black kid of stealing her
phone with no evidence
whatsoever so i'll show you the video
first yeah i've seen this one have you
seen it
i just haven't seen this
she just accuses the the black kid of
stealing her phone
and you know what she did she left the
phone in her car or in the hotel room
no
why would you she tackled the kid yeah
oh she did tackle the house about to say
he ain't go down anyways she's arrested
now and she was on that show with gail
what'd she say she said something like
he was when she lost her phone it was
that particular those people were the
ones that were walking by her at that
time
those people yeah she's also not white
no i don't know she likes spent in
mexican or something like that yeah i
think she's like
or italian maybe puerto rican or
something like that maya poncero
yeah she's not white we don't claim
really just like uh anyway she's
arrested
she's arrested yeah what did she say
bend herself
she just that was her point like she she
doesn't care about color it's not about
color it's just that that person was
there when she lost her phone
that person just happened to be there
yeah that person just happened to be the
woman caught from saying to you
i know you said you could have handled
it better but i just don't think i would
randomly attack people yeah she's not
badly what you did what do you think
when you look at that video
you're standing there in your leggings
and your flip-flops and it looks like
you're just going
nuts for lack of a better word no i'm
not letting you walk away with my phone
but i don't feel that that is who i am
as a person i just feel like this one
mistake does define me but
i do sincerely from the bottom of my
heart apologize that if i made
the sun feel as if i assaulted him or if
i hurt his feelings or
the father's feelings i don't believe
one mistake defines anybody
but i i think when i look at that
particular video sorry why is she
outside she's inside you did
why would you do a zoom in one's in the
[ __ ] jungle and the others
do see that too right at the end of the
day the girl right
how weird is it like slamming me to the
ground and uh because you attacked the
sun
and it was throwing me and you also got
a dirty hat on this one
you know the girl uh alex cooper from
caller daddy she saw that
and she came out was like this is not
our merch yeah i do not [ __ ] with this
man
oh wow she went and put her on black oh
that's from a podcast
yeah caller daddy has a lot of merch
that says uh daddy on it so when this
came out i guess people were tagging her
she's like we do not claim this [ __ ]
like this who just
listen to your [ __ ] hell well
dummy's gonna dummy mm-hmm i feel like
we covered a lot today
i think we solved everything yeah yeah i
think yeah i think we did
bro you really did that that's pretty
much it all right kids bonus friday
episode
uh this crew will be in san marcos texas
january 29th and 30th san marcos texas
get your tickets now
tickets are almost oh hey oh
i didn't see that new website new
website
oh we got the mark whoa hey so how about
my friend diameter and said a lot of
guys are in our dms right now
chill yo y'all got to chill she got a
man
uh let's just leave that up uh anyway
january 29th through the 30th san marcos
texas get your tickets now
all think boy gear thick girl gear uh
get it thickboy.com
that's it love you guys be safe boom